Okay, welcome everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Connors. We're going to talk a little bit about cancer pain.
A lot of people with cancer have pain and you could
You could classify it in a couple different classifications. Sometimes it can be good to have pain with cancer
Not that we want to have pain, but it can be a good sign and sometimes it can be a bad sign
So that's what we're going to call cancer good pain bad pain
So different possible causes of pain with a person with a cancer diagnosis
Well, never want it could be associated with tumor growth and that's that's tends to be if you have cancer and you have pain
You tend to think, oh my gosh, I'm getting worse and that can be true. So if the cancer is growing
It can increase in pain now a lot of cancers
Don't have any pain associated with it and I have had many many patients who stage four cancers with
Diagnosed very large tumors and say they have zero pain completely zero pain
Because you have certain types of pain fibers that measure
Sensation different ways so like in the gut typically in the intestinal tract itself
Only if you're having tissue damage like the cells are breaking down and you're getting bleeding or you have
expansion of the gut
Either because of backed up feces or
Gas because of the tumor is occluding the lumen or if the
Cancer is expandile in the intestinal tract it will cause pain
But many times people with colorectal pain cancer don't have pain. It's only when it's expandile
And that's more that's common in different types of colorectal cancer
So you can also get pain if the tumor itself is pressing on other tissues other organs other nerves
Lots of people with cancer in the liver have no pain
Sometimes cancer in the breast and other organs have no pain prostate cancer could have no pain related to it
It has just secondary issues that are causing pain
But if the tumor is pressing on a nerve or other tissues certainly that can be a cause of pain if it's
Expansile or destructive bone metastasis
Many times almost always that will be painful
So if you have some deep bone pain and we'll talk about the distinguishing characteristics of that in a second
But that could definitely be a cause of pain
Then you can have pain associated with a specific therapy that's being done with the cancer
So if you're going through some sort of therapy
That could be the cause of pain and that could be good pain or bad pain if you have direct attack on the cancer
Let's say with
chemotherapy or with the rife machine or with a specific
Utraceutical approach or with radiation to the cancer the pain can cause can happen with lysis or even apoptosis
That's rapid of many cells you could get pain because of that or commonly with a therapeutic
Positive note of cancer. So these would be positive things
This is what I want my pain to cause because from if I'm having pain
Can be caused from a local immune response and that's
Many times the more common cause of a positive reason a person could have
Paid at their cancer. No, this is a picture here on the slide showing what an inflammatory
Immute response would be okay. You jab yourself with a needle or
You know
A sliver of some kind and it irritates the skin breaks the skin surface
It sends out all these different chemical cytokines in the second little picture there. It telling the
immune system to respond to this site because there may be a bacterial infection there may be
You know something that could
It made the body and and kill this person so the immune system responds by what the
Local immune system in the tissue itself and coming from the blood to send in different T cells
Macrophages and immune response to kill
Whatever infection might be there and that is can cause local swelling
That's going to cause a local inflammatory response the area can be injured
You can even get this in a spray dangle. There's a perfect example of this like twist my ankle damaged tissue
Now my body doesn't understand where the damage came from could it be from some outside source like a puncture wound
So you have this huge inflammatory response all these white blood cells all these macrophages T cells
Attack the area to kill any
Uh
possible bacteria that could have made the body and kill the person and you get all this swelling
So well, we did you know, I sprayed my ankle. I didn't um, I don't I don't need a an immune response to the area
So we ice it and we elevate it and try to decrease that inflammatory response
But when we're trying to kill cancer one of the reasons why
You're not killing cancer if the cancer is growing is that your immune system is not
Recognizing very well
That the cancer is not self-tissue because the cancer is self-tissue
So then your immune system is not supposed to attack self-tissue and when we are trying to
Uh
To add therapies to get the immune system to attack the cancer
Um, we don't want to stop that. So a local immune response to a cancer following therapy
So we're going to give you a lot of immune stimulants and oh my cancer is actually gotten a little bit larger since I started care
Um, that's it doesn't always happen, but that can be a response or and it's really because the inflammation around there the swelling
That is involved with this inflammatory response that brings
Immune cells that can kill the cancer is what's taking place. We don't want to stop that
So we'll discuss that in a second too
And then you can get paid associated with cancer therapy because the pain is associated with destruction of healthy tissue
And that would be really with chemotherapy side effects
Radiation tissue damage that's what this picture in the upper left hand quarter is
Skin damage from radiation or post surgical healing. So I have damaging of healthy tissue because of my cancer therapy
And my pain might not even be near the cancer. So I'm doing chemotherapy for
colorectal cancer and I have paid all over my body. I'm sick. I'm nauseous. I'm throwing up by chest hurts, you know my feet hurt
You know
Well because the chemotherapy is attacking healthy tissue and you're getting the side effects thereof
So then we'd want to look at some detoxification work
You can also get referred pain with cancer. So referred pain means the pain that I have at this specific site
Has nothing to do with cancer at that specific site, but it's referred pain either
neurologically or dermatologically or the dermatones following the dermatones
Or specific referral points. Here's a chart of some different pain referral area. So
You see this picture on the left hand side is picture of the liver gall bladder can refer to the right
Shoulder upper trap area both on the front and the back the scale eat area
The lug in the diaphragm can refer to the opposite side on the left side and this is never a perfect scenario here
But this gives you some idea of where things can refer
Pain to and what organ can actually be associated with there's other
Charts that follow specific nerve pathways. Let's say if I have cancer at my first lumbar
vertebrae that's metastasized to the bone
What's gonna refer it could refer a pain all the way around the belly and it could refer a pain down to the hip socket
That's where L1 nerve root would follow
So
Metastasis from let's say prostate cancer to the sacrum l5 area can refer paid all the way down the leg can refer paid into the foot
It's the big toe
So you could get dermatological
Pathways where that nerve flows referred pain and it can have nothing to do with that area
so for instance right shoulder pain can have can be
Pain that has nothing to do with anything going on with the right shoulder
There's no metastasis to the shoulder
The joint is fine the muscles are fine, but the pain is you know, it intends
Great seven eight paid in the in the in the right shoulder
You have to start thinking of liver gall bladder issue actually the gall bladder could refer to the left shoulder as well
And this picture shows on the posterior side of the person's body that it doesn't go down very far
But actually liver gall bladder could go down to really T7 which is considerably lower than this picture shows here
so
Just think about those things when a person has paid
That it's a referred pain from a different from an organ site and they this could be a bad thing because if there's
referred pain
From a cancer growing. It's that's not necessarily a good thing
It can be a good thing and then it could be a referred pain because of this because of the inflammation that's at that
Uh, the local immune response at the cancer site is causing that referred pain
So that's a possibility of differential diagnosis that is very difficult without doing some scans and tests
And we'll discuss that
So and then you can have paid that's unrelated to the cancer now always when we have a cancer diagnosis
We tend to think of anything that we have going on as related to the cancer. Okay. Oh my gosh by foot hurts
Oh, I have cancer in my footer. Is that referred pain?
Or did you just twist your ankle or did you sleep on it wrong or do you have arthritis?
How many people over age 50 have some
degree of degenerative arthritis and their spine and then and you're sleeping differently because of other issues
with your cancer and you're holding yourself differently and you're not getting as that exercise
All these things are related and we want to be careful not to attribute any symptoms that we have
To the cancer without at least investigating other possible causes and
And you want to investigate those other possible causes of treating that so
I'm hit some differential diagnosis this paid associated with tumor growth typically
It can occur with or without concurrent therapy. So if I
My tumors growing well, I'm not I haven't changed the chemotherapy. I'm doing or I haven't changed any of my
Therapy that I've been doing my alternative therapy with the rife and nutrition for three months
And now my pain has increased. Okay. Well, that's a little red flag there
So nothing has changed for the last three months
But your pain just increased a week ago and it's continuing to increase or it's continuing to be at a higher level
We want to do some digging that's that's a red flag that something change something is going on
tumor position pressing on nerves tissues confluxuate can be intermittent
Various degrees various different sensations that can happen with that many times
It'll be sharp if it's a nerve pain if it's pressing out a nerve if it's on the tissue on a tissue or an organ it can be very dull
So that's what is very difficult to differential diagnosed
Expands out destructive bone meds typically that's going to be dull unless there's a fracture of the bone involved that it's can be you know
Very sharp and debilitating
But prior to a fracture, it's typically going to be dull deep steady pain to take like I wouldn't but describe as a deep pain
That they can't really put their finger on it. It's just this deep bone pain
That may times referred pain can be deep pain too
But it's not going to be at a specific site like it's right there
A referred pain is going to be more of it. It's here, but it's in the size of like the
A grapefruit to right around there. Is it right here? Well kind of it feels like right there
I don't know. That's going to be the difference with referred pain. It's going to be real hard to pinpoint it
With bone metastasis. It's going to be easier to pinpoint it like it's coming from right there and you can put your figure on it
That's part of the differential diagnosis
Again, ultimately you're going to do a scan or an x-ray or something to find that out
Direct attack on a cancer typically is
Aligned with the beginning a course of a care. So I just started with the rife
And oh my gosh the pain in my breasts has just increased
You know dramatically since I started with the right. Well actually that's a good sign
Now understand it's not a bad sign if I just started with the rife and I didn't feel any different
This it's not that's not a bad sign
Um, you're as a bad sign. I started with a rife and my cancer is shrunken
I feel a lot better. Well of course, that's a good sign. So it doesn't mean that
Everybody who starts a new course of care whether it be chemo therapy or rife or
specific nutraceutical therapy that they will have pain at that cancer
But typically if you have a pain at that cancer site after starting a specific course of therapy
correlates exactly with
You know near that start or right after that start of that therapy. It's usually a good sign
It's a sign of lysis usually if that's the case or the in a local immune response
So both of those can be severe at times they can be extremely painful
Um, but usually it's um a good sign
So pain associated with the destruction of healthy tissue
As in chemo therapy radiation and post surgical healing
Well, that's pretty easy to differential diagnose because it happened after the care and you're getting it
It's not at the cancer site itself
And the scans may show that the cancer is not receding
But you're getting a lot of pain at other areas
And then referred pain from cancer typically worsens
And I should say as as the cancer progresses
So um
That's what you and that could be dull again
And again the differential diagnose so that it could be hard to like pain point. Oh, it's in my shoulder
Well as somebody's pointed here here. Yeah, there is it over here too kind of yeah
It's hard. It's it's it's kind of vague. It's a much more vague. No, it can be extremely severe pain
Um, and then what are some care options? What do we do about these things?
So pain associated with tumor growth
Will you certainly want to adjust the current care?
So let's say if I, you know, do we started at our clinic and you're doing well for three months and all of a sudden
You have this increased pain
And um, and it's it's slowly getting worse over a course of a week
We need to that's why I said it's a red flag. Well, you need to call us
So we need to talk about we need to tweak something what else do we need to do do we need to add something what do we need to do
Um, that's not necessarily a good sign
Um, what can you do if you have tumor
Uh, positional pain the tumor is pressing on nerves. It's damaging the tissue itself. It's expands out to the tissue itself
Well, think of things like curcute clear. That's a curcumin
Uh, terriva, which is a whole food
Uh
Um
Curcumin-a-way product that's
From turmeric whole food turmeric clear inflamed, which has a bunch of different anti-inflammatories in there, including ginger, but I put ginger there too
limitless that I have a
podcast on and a blog post on what this product is. It's got beta lens
That is a patented process how they get the beta lens, which is probably
One of the most anti-inflammatory things that we have from a from a nutraceutical standpoint
Think of things like CBD THC
THC can be probably the most powerful
Uh
None drug
Tool that we have
Uh, that can help people with pain
Um, so always consider THC therapies like pemf tens unit
Could help with uh, tuber positional pain
Expansile bone meds think of all the above, but add certainly add CG
EGCG, which is the
Catacombs from green tea extract our product is uh terriva
Uh, that's uh, that's not terriva, but it's t
Tivago that's what it is Tivago is our product
Um pain associated with cancer therapy if it's a direct attack on the cancer
And again, it's typically aligned in the beginning of a course of cancer care
If it's from direct lysis, let's say you're just started chemotherapy and your your your breast pain is really really bad
Go back to those all those anti-inflammatories that we just talked about
If the pain um is occurring from a local immune response would be which would be
I'm just starting a natural approach
I just started with the rife and I have a lot of increased pain
Yes, you could use curcumin, so I would say you know, I put it here non anti-inflammatories even though curcumin
Uh, tuberic is a considered anti-inflammatories also so high in the cancer killer list
Uh, there's so many studies on how well it can do as far as just killing cancer
I would not exclude those
With the local immune response issues, but we're not trying to the reason I said non anti-inflammatories is that the goal is it to
Decrease the inflammation and we want that inflammatory response
Now understand there's a difference between a chronic inflammatory response from chronic disease
chronic ill health poor diet which can cause cancer
Versus an acute inflammatory response which is an immune response and immune attack to that site
So we're talking about the site of a cancer. We want an immune attack to the site of the cancer
That's how coli's talk and toxins therapy worked
I have data on that on my on my website in the in years past that's we can't do anymore. It's against the law
And it worked because you're basically producing a local inflammatory response
That could help the body kill that cancer. That's that's how
Infrared heat deep infrared heat it works same thing
That's what we're doing. We're adding
immune stimulants which is
Everybody who's on a cancer killer
Neutraceutical from our office. That's an immune stimulant. We're trying to create that local immune response
So we don't want to take on much anti-inflammatories to negate that per se so we think it's therapies like PEMF and 10s unit
They could help because they work a different way they block the pain
Pathway with not really decreasing the inflammation CBD and THC again is always a thing that you could use for pain
Because even though this might be a good paid quote unquote
It's not real fun. So you still want to yes, you tolerate, but is there ways to decrease the pain?
Without decreasing the local inflammation
Yes, there are
Pain associated with the destruction of healthy tissues. Obviously you're thinking of detoxification therapies because we just got to get those poisons out of the body
So that that will decrease and referred pain from cancer
Well, then you go back to the anti-inflammatories to try to decrease that
Just that rate that pain
And of course pain unrelated to the cancer make sure that you find the cause
Okay, hopefully that was helpful. I am going to unmute us and open it up to questions and questions about this or
Unrelated topics are ready for the next 15 minutes
So
If you have a question just
Let me know
Dr. Connors is there a right program that you would recommend um like for arthritis or fibromyalgia
so for arthritis um so
Remember there's two different
kinds of arthritis
So there's degenerative arthritis and inflammatory arthritis so degenerative arthritis
Is it what I mentioned here earlier? Is that everybody gets we have you know wear and tear under joints and you have
Arthritis due to just degeneration of those joints can be worse if you had an old injury
And that joint can you know decay away and that can be extremely painful
Um, is there a rife program for that a rife isn't gonna really heal that I would always think with any
Musculoskeletal issues to
To use um
You could use some swelling programs. I think there's some inflammatory programs
There's accelerated healing and the normalizing frequency
Program but really
The degenerative arthritis rife isn't gonna like do massive benefits to that
So you want to look at other things too
Um, if it's in a large joint capsule filled joint like your knee or ankle or your shoulder
They could right and glucosamine
Any of these anti-inflammatories that we discuss here would be beneficial for that
um
If it's a the different type of arthritis, which is called inflammatory arthritis that's caused from
some inflammatory agent those are
uh
Like rheumatoid
Arthritis which these are all autoimmune diseases all the inflammatory arthritis is and there's a causal factor to those many times
um
Many times it's a toxin usually it's a toxin
We used to see a lot of done cancer patients
We saw a lot of
inflammatory autoimmune arthritis and very common it was a heavy metal toxicity
So doing detoxification or could be helpful with that
Um, and different anti-inflammatories could be helpful with that too
So that's where the rife can be more beneficial with the inflammatory arthritis because you can do the foot detox
and um some of the other detox programs that could be beneficial
Um, make sure again when you're looking at detox that you're going through those
um
Pathways of detoxification that you don't want to be trying to detox heavy metals out of your tissue
If you're only having a bowel with every two days
Because you will just make yourself more toxic or if you have cancer in your liver you don't want to be
Trying to do that also which are which is going to just could be overloading to your liver
So you want to use caution with that when you're dealing with other
Issues like cancer but
If you do have any of those issues
Um, make sure you
Um, bring them up on the Facebook page too so I can see who's asking
We could get more specific answers for you as as an individual too
Dr. Connors, this is Marie
Yes
Um, I have a question. I'm wondering about detoxing
Uh, your body if uh
For
Possibly parasites
Like liver flukes or anything like that. Is there any kind of a particular detox
Uh, that you would recommend
Yeah, so uh
So parasites, so if we classify parasites as anything that's living off of you
Um in an unhealthy way
Um
Including your teenage children
Then there's different ways to deal with that
Of course not you're not going to detox your teenage children, but sometimes it's uh, it's a must
But anyhow, that's another subject so parasitic infections like liver flukes
Um typically liver flukes uh, the old saying was uh, clove
Everybody for a second
Uh, typically liver flukes
It's been said that liver clovees are the last meal of the liver fluke
We use a product called paratocin for liver flukes
Now again, um, I'm not suggesting that you jump into any parasite cleanse protocol
um
If you're dealing with stage 4 cancer and it's you know, very active
but um
So talk to us individually please about this
But we use proverma fuge as a general parasite cleanse
And paratocin as uh, that typically tests it can test for other parasites too
But at that typically test for liver flukes usually if a person's
Testing for parasites and you can lock it in over the liver paratocin's gonna
That's that's gonna test out
But also we have paraclear which is uh has wormwood and some other things in it
But not as many things as the proverma fuge
So there's multiple different parasite
Cleanses that you could use depending on if it's a tapeworm or roundworm in the attestinal tract
Or if it's a liver fluk or it's something systemic or it's in your brain or it's you know
Because parasites different types of parasites can attack you in all different areas of your body
But um, those are that's a good question parasites are
A lot more common than people think there was an article out in the
AMA journal. Oh, it was about 10 years ago. I think that said it if you live in the southern half of the United States
You have I don't know it's like an astronomical number like 85% chance that you heart that you have a parasite
You don't know what if you live in the northern half of the United States
There's a 35% chance that you have a parasite. You don't know it
Um, just because
Down south where it's warmer. They don't die. You could get them most common source of parasite
In your body is going to be your pets animals that you are exposed to
Outside your exposed to parasites hookworms all sorts of different things food that you eat
That is improperly cooked
We've had patients with
Trichodosis as a cause for cancer
Trichodosis to cause for severe migraines
Ah, you think Trichodosis are you kidding? That's from undercook pork
Um, yeah, so it's just it's crazy parasites are real and they're real common
Any other questions?
Someone asked a question about the corona virus and is that a serious thing to consider
And what should we do about it? Are there some things that we could do about it? Yes
Is it serious? Should we consider it a serious threat?
Um, I don't know yet. There's a lot of
Information that is coming out of different sources that it's hard to know the bias of that information
Um, I tend to be extremely skeptical
Uh, different diseases that uh, the mainstream
Uh, media tells us that we're all going to die from and
Scareous people into getting doing things that maybe they wouldn't do if they were thinking clearly
And not functioning completely out of fear like getting very
inadequate
Vaccinations that have adjuvunks that can cause all sorts of problems including cancer
Um, and I wonder who is gaining out of some of these fearful tactics that
I mean uh, ever since I can remember
Almost every year we're going to die of something
Whether it's Zika or whatever it is
Uh, now the corona virus and they're going to have come out with a vaccine against it to make billions
Uh, by using those fear tactics now
Is it possible that it is really a scary virus and there's there's there's there is
Um, adequate data to warrant
Uh, fear or action that should be taken
I don't know that's possible
What can you do from an actual perspective?
Well certainly most of the things that all our cancer patients are doing
Like I said, you are on immune stimulants
So taking immune stimulants are beneficial
Um, also there's certain specific viral
Uh, killers from a natural perspective
We have a product called viral clear
Which um, we use for a lot of people with viruses
Um
Burberry is a great antiviral antibacterial
Um, there's there's a lot of things that we use for viral things as far as the rife goes
You have a viral complex program that you could certainly run
Plus if you update your rife and remember how to update your rife if you've been
Um, if you started with us in the last month or so your
The new corona virus program should be on your rife
If it's not on your rife then you can uh, log into the internet and then and any page on the rife
You hit update as long as you're connected to the internet it takes about five minutes to download
Anything new that was created by true rife or us that it will be in your program
And it will not interrupt or disrupt the program that we created for you
so um
Again true rife came out with a corona virus program. You can run the viral program take antiviral things
You just be wise in what you're doing and by all means you do not do a vaccine for something like this
And cause more problems. So
All right, any other questions
This is Claudia um
Can I ask a question? I don't want to ask a question until everyone has their cancer
questions answered
So I'm just waiting oh you just go
Okay, okay, thank you um
We do want to come out to see you that I wanted to check about the timing whether it should be sooner or whether it should be a day either
Um, I think everything was okay with the cancer um, but my concern is my memory and um, I kind of figured that that maybe
We had moved about six months ago and the neighborhood we moved into his five G and it doesn't have
The telephone poles with them on it, you know, I was really happy. I didn't realize that there was five G here
Um, you know, they didn't have the telephone poles that they have those boxes. We have underground wiring and there's a
Box that kind of looks like a small refrigerator in our front yard. I don't know if that has anything to do with when I'm experiencing
Um, when we first moved in
I was experiencing dizziness during the night and so I turned lost our
router
During the night which that helped but I'm still experiencing well memory problems ringing in my ears
um
I have some really Parkinson's symptoms which you have already
Like you know, they're in the bed. I guess because of my genes
um, and so I'm
So I guess pretty much memory problems, sleep problems, and really bad ringing in my ears all kinds of noises
Um, as long as I keep the five G off during the night, I haven't been dizzy
Um, whenever my mother and I was dying and I slept
Um, with at the nursing home in her room for a week
When I slept there, I slept well now. I slept on like a really comfortable mattress
So I don't know if it was that or if it was the um, you know, if it was just the mattress or if it adds to do with our environment
That I'm having problems sleeping. So I guess my question is if I have all kinds of Alzheimer's
Um, you know, documentaries and um, I could look into all of that and try different things or should I just
Come in and be checked out for everything
Should I work on some things here or should I come in sooner and have you check out things before me trying to figure them out?
Okay, so number one um
Uh, never I posted for you to send us your updated e-mail
Okay, because when I like I did create an all-cylverse
Dimension early-dimension Parkinson's protocol
And uh, okay, and I tried to e-mail it to you when it kept bouncing back
Okay, you know
Last six months or something
So if you could just e-mail the clinic
Write that down so you remember to do that and then I will send that to you
Because I've had that done over a week. So I want to get that over. Yeah
Yeah, you know, I did I don't know if Michelle said something. I thought I sent something to you that I probably didn't
Yeah, I will go ahead and do that. No, no, I probably didn't because you wouldn't there run in me
Um, you know, if you could do that again, that would be great
But that in itself just a general protocol. I mean, I could literally post it up on the Facebook page because it would be good
general protocol for early-dimension
Alzheimer's
Uh, or Parkinson's it anybody could do that
Yeah, that's not a specific protocol if you're going to come here and be better to test you on these things
You don't mind things that are necessarily going to be beneficial for you
Plus we do want to get to the cause it would you started to open up that door a little bit
Could it be the 5G? Could it be the electric so that that thing that looks like a refrigerator out your front yard
That is not your
That's not the 5G
Uh, that is yeah, that's the other ground electrical
So that's that's electricity committed to your house now can you have dirty electricity at your house
That's causing issues why sure you can dirty electricity can be a source of EMF damage
Um, and exposure to your house
So um, um, definitely I'd say that's a possibility
Um, but the 5G in the area that is that's um coming through your walls from some tower
That's hope that's uh yourself on tower that's somewhere within a mile of your house
Oh, okay, okay
Um, and then to come back that um, that's a little bit more difficult
Yeah, turning off your router at night that helps turning off your cell phone at night putting your cell phone
Faraday cage of some sort like the we got to do
Um things in the bags in that we created that are
Put your router in
That you can throw your phone in keep your phone away from your
Out of your bedroom at night even if it's turned off
um
But still you have 5G that's
Tread traversing through your body just if you don't have any receiver near that it's going to be less
So that's those are beneficial things um
And then uh, and then we do want to check there's other possible
Oh, this my symptom is worse since I moved it can't be due to EMF sources near that place
It could be used due to dirty electricity like we talked about it can be due to
So a discovered uh mold or something like that too, so um, that's where have you here tested you would be beneficial
So that oh perfect it would be sooner rather than later than I guess
Okay, good and we do I just look on outside of our house and we do have a smart weave neither
Pretty much beside our bedroom on our outside wall, so that may
Um, you know, that that may have
You give me one of those bags that we have you could you could put that outside as well and just
Fascinate to that smart meter around the smart meter that will help too
Or you could call the electrical company and demand that they come and remove that
Oh, good. Okay. I would rather have a pick on
Okay, so then the plan should be to come out soon um as opposed to trying to fix it myself then
Yeah, because we might be just throwing darts at the board with we don't
If we don't know, but so if you're going to come maybe sooner than later
Yes, yes, and I will send you my email then
Okay, well, thank you very much
I'm sorry. I and um, I have my daughter is from music and I'm watching three little ones
So anyway
Okay, we'll go first you thank you. We will um, I'll talk to George and then we'll get them up there
Okay, so it's good another one okay said um, but happy headaches
Since coming in this week nothing bad is there something I should do
For that well headaches, okay? Is it because so the thing I didn't talk about
And now that just reminded me I guess I should need to redo my slight presentation
Is paid from a possible detoxification
Herkseimer reaction and that's not uncommon either that would fall into pain associated with cancer there the therapy itself
So you're doing some sort of therapy that's causing detoxification
And typically a common symptom of that is a headache
So you get a toxic headache after you know starting with the right machine
That's a sign of lysis usually
So because it's endotoxins that are causing the
inflammation and the vascular
Uh in the in the brain
So yes, you could definitely you could do some infusion of essential oils if that makes you feel better
But really it's increasing your water intake
Doing a foot bath program
If you have a sona doing a sona doing a hot pad over your liver
Doing a castoral pack over your liver if possible to do a coffee
Enema so detoxification things is what you think of
Doing an Epsom salt bath
Doing an Epsom salt foot bath
Those are the things that I would suggest for certainly there's nothing wrong with taking something to cut that
If it's a really bad headache of course
The headache is there remember all pain is a sign just keep that in mind pain is a sign of something going on
It's really an alert system for your body. It's a larb telling you that there's something something happening
It's not always a bad thing. That's what we discussed today
But it's not always pleasant. It doesn't mean you want to keep it the pain. I mean
Even if a good thing is taking place that's causing it. So look, you know, go back and watch this again
Look at these different possible things that you can do
Add that paid associate with cancer therapy that I just discussed there detoxification
Pain herk cyber pain
And think about detoxification pathways for that
All right
No other questions
We will sign off for tonight
Make sure you ask questions on the Facebook page as well and again for people who are new
If you have a question that is more private you can certainly ask it in the chat
You don't want your name up
And certainly when you do ask a question there is no reason for you to say
Who you are unless you so desire to do so there's no reason to announce
I don't think anybody can see your name pop up when you talk so
And it
Ask that question in the chat if you have a personal question or email the question to the clinic email or the info at cutters clinic
But please put
Zoom call question in the message part so we just get so many emails that it will get lost so we won't address it
All right, well, thank you very much. We will see you all next week. Hopefully you'll have a very blessed week and the pain treat
All right, bye bye